The Democratic National
Convention
is at the end of next month,
which means
Hillary Clinton is running out
of time to accomplish
two important goals.
Number one--
find an outfit
that doesn't make her look
like Gary Oldman's character
from The Fifth Element.
-(laughter)
-BREWSTER: Aw.
-And...
-(applause)
Number two--
win ancient snow crab
Bernie Sanders over to her side.
That's why the two of them
got together on Tuesday
to learn what it would take
to get his endorsement.
Here he is trying
to get more packets of creamer
for his coffee.
This is all a very private,
casual affair.
Hillary ordered a pint of beer,
and Bernie ordered his favorite
cocktail-- Gas-X on a Beach.
But hopefully, they sort of
came to an agreement?
Such as... (as Bernie):
"I'll endorse Hillary
"if she promises
a $15 minimum wage, or
"I'll endorse Hillary if
she brings me a elixir of life
that allows me
to live through the convention."
So comedians, what are
some other possible concessions
that came out of their secret
Tuesday meeting?
-Paul F. -Hillary agrees
to attend Hamilton
and describe it to Bernie.
(laughter and groaning)
-Points. Points. Paget.
-BREWSTER: Oh!
Hillary and Bernie
will part brokenhearted,
but they will agree
to meet a year later
at the top
of the Empire State Building.
-(laughter, applause)
-You're a gentleman.
Just a game.